Hello, everybody.
My name is Dr.
Richard Morgan,
and once again,
I'm here for the
third installment
of three neurologic
DPR lectures.
This one is
entitled Sensory
Systems, Special
Techniques,
as well as more
documentation.
We're going to kind
of sum up and complete
the third, like
I said, and final
installment of the
neurologic lecture series.
Once again, the
session objectives will
be to learn how to
perform a neurologic
assessment of the
sensory system, as
well as the use of
the various special
techniques that we
will be demonstrating.
Next, we'll learn how
to obtain a detailed
health history in
a patient with a
neurologic complaint.
And finally, we will
once again review
documentation of the
physical findings
for a neurologic exam
and include the
sensory system as well.
Again, here's just more
of a recap from the
first two lectures
of all the components
as we go down the list,
including, and we've
already covered
mental status, cranial
nerves, motor, gait
coordination, as well
as reflexes. Now we're
going to move on to
the remainder of the
physical exam, including
sensation and other
special techniques.
Again, sensory pathways
are very complex.
You'll be reviewing them
in your neuroanatomy.
It's more or less
something more
for documentation here
and for references.
But just note that
they do participate in
reflex activity, those
sensory impulses, including
conscious sensation,
local body position
and space, helping to
regulate the internal
autonomic functions
as well as heart rate,
respiration, and blood
pressure. And these
are all things that we're
going to be practicing
over and over in the
lab. I just want you
to see the clinical
correlation between the
neuroanatomy and
physiology and how we're
going to be performing
these things in labs.
What does sensation
include? Well,
there's a number of
terms that we use
to notify sensation,
Starting with
analgesia, which is
the absence of pain.
You don't feel it.
Hypalgesia, who
is decreased
sensitivity to pain.
Hyperalgesia, it can
be increased pain
sensitivity, also
known in some cases
as a severe form,
something called
allodynia, which is
increased pain to light
sensation. And
that's often seen in
something called reflex
sympathetic dystrophy
or chronic regional
pain syndrome,
which will go over in
your neural lectures.
Anesthesia is
the complete
absence of
touch sensation.
Hyposthesia is decreased
sensitivity to touch.
Hyperesthesia is
increased sensitivity to
touch. And then finally,
paresthesias are a
sensation of like a
numbness or tingling or
pins and needles that
often can be felt when
nerves are being
compromised or compressed.
What are we testing
when we look at
the sensory system?
There's a number of
components, including
the following.
Number one, pain and
temperature. Now,
that involves the
spinal thalamic tracts,
position sense,
appropriate reception,
as well as vibration,
which involves
the dorsal and
posterior columns,
and then light touch,
spinal thalamic and
posterior columns,
and then finally,
two-point or
discriminative sensations,
which depend
on some of the
sensations listed
above, as well as
also processed by
the sensory cortex.
how do we sense how do
we test for the sensory
well we're going to
go through all these
one by one the most
important general rules
as with most things
that we do when we
do our physical exam
is we always compare
both sides we want to
make sure it's symmetrical
and we go left to
right immediately want
to check the exact
region or location on
one side to the other
to get that immediate
correlation to
determine whether or not
there is a reduced
sensation or diminished
sensation on one of
the two sides. Next, we
always want to compare
proximal versus distal.
The shoulder, which
is proximal, and then
the wrist and hand,
which is more distal.
Testing these
components can often
lead to a possible
location of where
the lesions are
occurring, and that
includes pain,
temperature, and touch.
Next is vibration and
position sense, We
test fingers and
toes distantly first,
and we'll go through
those tests as well,
as well as vary the
pace of the testing.
Next, we want to map
out the boundaries
of sensory loss or
hypersensitivity.
Every location of
sensory will coincide
with a specific
region. It could be
regionally the axial
spine based on the lumbar
sacral region where
it's coming from,
or it could be
dermatoma, meaning a
specific location along
the skin. And I'll
show you some pictures
of that as well.
Dermatomes and peripheral
nerve patterns.
Okay, here's some
more terminology,
again, that you'll
cover in neuro
and neuroanatomy as
well. But dermatomes
are a band of skin
innervated by the
sensory root of a
single spine nerve.
Each spinal nerve,
as it exits,
innervates a specific
area of skin, and
they're often correlated
with that nerve.
So once you are
able to determine
a decreased sensory
component in
a specific area,
you can often
correlate it back
to that nerve root.
Next is peripheral
nerve patterns, which
can indicate areas
innervated by a specific
nerve. And then, of
course, knowledge of
the dermatomes and
peripheral nerve patterns
help to localize the
neurologic lesion
to a specific level
of the spinal cord or
nerve that is affected.
This is really
where anatomy and
clinical correlation comes
together. So understanding
your anatomy,
knowing over and
over again when you
start to practice
where the loss or
location of sensation
may be decreased and
how it correlates
with either a nerve
root or a nerve
pattern will often go
towards really
having a best way to
understand how to
treat these patients.
Here's an example
of some diagrams
of what dermatomes
look like.
The left side is
broken down dermatomes
by skin region,
as you can see.
You'll be given
these throughout the
course of your
neurologic neuroanatomy
training. So become
familiar with them.
Prifinal nerve
patterns. And
remember, some are
more common than
others, okay? It's
really important.
For instance, if you
find there's a band
or distribution
along, you know, the
lateral aspect of
your left leg, right?
then you have an
idea as to that it's
possibly coming from
L4, L5, L2, L3, L4.
You'll get an idea
what nerve root is
involved and potentially
what peripheral
nerve patterns are
involved. So there's
going to be ones that
are more common than
others, especially
cervical and lumbar
sacral. So really
be comfortable with
those patterns and
know that when there's
a deficit or when
there's a loss of
sensation, what is the
clinical correlation?
Again, sensory testing
will involve
the following.
We can test for pain,
hot and cold temperature,
light touch
vibration, as well as
proprioception and
discriminative sensations.
Sensory testing of
dermatomes is done,
obviously, bilaterally,
as I said. And
what we're going to
be doing is going to
be touching multiple
areas of the body with
a sharp or semi-sharp
object. Oftentimes
we use a cotton
tool tip applicator.
The light touch,
usually we use the tip,
which is the cotton
tip, and then the semi
-sharp or sharp end,
we either use the end
of the wooden stick,
as you can see in
the picture, or sometimes
if you really are
having a difficult
time, you can break
the stick in half and
lightly use the semi
-sharp end, the sharpened
end of the tip.
Those are how we're
going to be doing
them, and they should
be done with the
patient's eyes closed
and always go side
to side along the
same dermatomal path.
So if you're doing,
like in this picture,
you're doing a light
touch and sharpness
to the left forearm,
then you should go
right and do it to the
right side as well.
Now sensory testing
using vibration.
Here's where we take
our tuning fork. we
usually use the 128
hertz which is the larger
ones in your kit we
place that tuning
fork over the distal ip
joint which is either
the finger or the toe
you have it vibrate
and then you hold the
patient hold their
finger out and ask
them if they can feel
this and you again
have them close their
eyes see if they can
feel it and have them
give the local any
vibration that's
impaired it's going to
be more proximal bone
of if vibration is
impaired test the more
proximal bony prominence,
such as the wrist,
elbow, medium allele,
shin, and so on and
so forth. You want
to move your way up.
Usually, if there's
any kind of vibration
deficit, it'll be
more distal, and then
you should work your
way more proximal
as you go along to
see where the impaired
component, the
location, the region is.
Often the first
sensation, as I said,
loss in peripheral
neuropathy is distal.
So, you know, when
you're going to go into
this, when you cover
diabetes and your
neurology and
neuronatic elections,
peripheral neuropathies
are most commonly
distal. So if a patient
has a history of long
-term diabetes or they
have that sensation
of pins and needles
occasionally in
their fingers or toes
and it's been getting
worse, this is
definitely something that
you want to check
and to determine not
only whether or not
vibration is present
or exactly where the
location is as well.
Next, we're going to
do proprioception,
which is joint
position sense.
Again, very important,
a little tricky
to do if it's got to
be done correctly.
So, joint position
sense, test the fingers
and toes first. So,
what you do, if the
distal joints are
normal, most likely
proprioception is intact
and proximal joints. So,
what you do, as you
can see in this picture
on the lower left, as
the examiner, you're
standing in front
of the patient, have
them close their eyes.
You're gently placing
your fingers between
two of the proximal
interphalangeal joints
and very gently,
almost very, very
subtle, you're going to
slightly flex or extend
the patient's finger.
You have them ask
them if it feels like
it's moving up or down.
You can move it literally
a millimeter. And
if you do it on
yourself or do it with
a family member, you'll
see it's very easy
if you have normal
proprioception to know
even the slightest
movement to be able to
tell. But a lot of times,
people with peripheral
neuropathies and
other vascular diseases
in their distal
extremities oftentimes
have a very difficult
time determining
proprioception. So it's got
to be done subtly.
It's got to be done
very, very, very
carefully to pay attention
to which side is or
is not being affected.
Now, discriminative
sensations.
This tests the
ability of the
sensory cortex
to correlate,
analyze, or
interpret sensations.
Touch and position
sense need to be intact
for tests. All right.
Absence or decrease in
discriminative sensation
includes a lesion,
possibly most likely
in the sensory cortex.
And once again,
patient's eyes should be
closed for all of
these discriminative
tests. We need to have
touch and position
sense intact. Otherwise,
they won't be able
to perform these
tests accurately and
you won't be able to
get accurate results.
What are some of the
discriminative tests?
OK, these are tests.
There are three most
commonly that we
use here. Stereognosis
is the identifying
of an object in
touch. So you take a
very common option,
be a pen or a pen
cap or a key, as in
this picture here.
You have the patient
close their eyes,
place the object
in their hand,
and simply ask them
if they can feel
it and what they
think the object is.
And then usually
most of you will be
able to determine
that. But again, people
who have lacked
position sense and
things like that
can have an often
difficult time telling
what the object is.
Second, grapesthesia
is number
identification, where
you can identify
the number drawn on
a patient's palm.
In the picture, we
use a pen so that it
illustrates what you're
doing. You can simply
use a cotton tip
applicator or a sharp
end of a pen cap that's
not on and just draw
the number without
drawing. We don't
want people drawing
all over people's hands
in labs, so you don't
need to specifically
draw the number, but
just for illustrative
purposes, that's what
we're doing here.
And then next is two
-point discrimination.
Taking a paperclip and
touching two places
simultaneously using
the open ends will help
determine if the patient
can feel one or both
points. Normal
minimal distance for
discrimination here will
vary for different parts
of the body. You know,
when there's more
nerve endings, you can
often tell a very, very
close distance between
the paperclips. So,
but people with significant
diminished sensation
and discrimination
will have a very hard
time determining those
points. So you start
as close as you can.
If they can't tell,
they move it a millimeter
or two further apart
and ask the patient
if they feel one, two,
or ask them what they
feel. And if they say
they feel it, ask them
how many points they
feel. And normal,
obviously, is two points.
Here's some more
discriminative sensation
testing. This one's
point localization.
Again, it's intuitive
and simplistic
in its way. It's
performed with
the patient's eyes
closed. You briefly
touch any place
on their skin.
Upper body, lower
body, arms, whatever,
you know, you want
to test on something
that's easily
accessible and then
ask the patient
to open their eyes
and point to the
place that's touched.
So you briefly
touch it, you remove
the object and ask
him to literally
demonstrate where
you had just touched.
And if there's a
patient with a lesion in
the sensory cortex,
their ability to localize
that point will be
significantly impaired.
And then next is
extinction. So, again, with
the patient's eyes
closed, we simultaneously
stimulate areas on
both sides of the
body, generally the
same point, such as the
biceps or the upper
arms in this picture.
The patient will identify
the location of
the stimulus.
With the sensory cortex
lesions, only one
stimulus may be felt,
and this stimulus
that is not recognized
is extinguished.
And it would be on
the contralateral
side that is being
affected. So it's
one way you can
tell if there's an
impairment of the
sensory cortex due
to the contralateral
sensory loss.
Here are some
techniques that
we often include
towards the
end of the
neurologic lecture.
We'll go through each one
of these individually.
Brudinsky and Koenig
signs are both tests
for meningitis. Then
we have some tests
for cervical
radiculopathy or herniated
discs in the neck,
including axial compression
and pyramidal
distraction, as well as
the Spurling test, by
the way. It's skipped
down a spot. And
then we'll go into a
few other tests with
using the legs and
looking for lumbar
radiculopathy and possibly
a malignering patient
in the UBER test.
All right, meningeal
signs, important. This
is a condition that
you definitely want
to identify early,
since untreated, this
can cause significant
morbidity mortality.
Meningitis is an
extremely important
diagnosis to make
early on, especially
if there's signs
of fever, neck
stiffness, and mental
status changes.
This test is suspected
when meningeal
inflammation from
either meningitis or
subarachnoid hemorrhage
can be present, and the
two most common
tests that we will be
practicing in lab are
Brudzinski and Kernan.
What do these signs do?
Brudzinski.
When you lie the
patient supine and you
slightly flex the
head and neck forward,
as you have this
patient licepine flat,
and when you lift the
head and neck forward,
flexion, there would
be, if the Brudzinski
sign is present,
there'd be a natural
response for the hip and
knee, or I should say
pathological response
for the hip and knee,
relax will now be
flexed automatically as
you flex the neck.
There'll be a simultaneous
flexion of both
hips and knees. Very
important to recognize
this. Due to a
constant inflammation
along throughout the
entire spinal cord,
any sort of problem or
irritation of the
cervical spine will cause
a subsequent
inflammation or response
to the lower extremity.
And that's why we
get this response.
The second test is
Kerning's. This is done
on the leg this time,
where you have the
patient's leg flex at
the hip and knee while
the patient's lying
supine. The physician
takes the leg and
flexes it as it is
shown in this picture.
Once the leg is flexed
at the knee and the
ankle, you slowly extend
the leg and straighten
the knee. A positive
Kerning's sign would
be pain and increase
resistance to knee
extension as you bring
the leg back down. How
can we remember what
these tests are? Very
easy. I like to remember
B for Brutzynski is
brain, therefore it's
the neck, and K for
Koenig is the knee.
So K Koenig is done at
the lower extremity, B
Brutzynski is done at
the upper extremity.
And once again, we'll
be practicing these
important tests in lab.
Axial compression test.
This is a test for
cervical neck impingement.
With the patient
seated just as such
in the picture and
the physician standing
behind, you rest
the elbows on the
shoulders and gently place
a downward compression
with your hands
resting on top of the
patient's head. You
exert a downward
force firmly, but not
causing an increased
amount of pain, all
right? The test is positive
if pain or neurologic
symptoms are reproduced
in the cervical
spine and or upper
extremity. As soon
as the patient reports
any discomfort, the
test should be
completed, and it should
be deemed a positive
test, okay? So this
is how the axial
compression test is done.
Straightforward, the
patient is looking
ahead. There's no side
bending or rotation,
and it's a simple
straight downward force.
Framal distraction,
okay? This is a test
for cervical nerve
impingement. So with
the patient seated
on the table, the
examiner places one
hand under the patient's
shin as seen here,
with the other hand
under the occiput,
the back of the head.
Gently, an upward
traction force
applied on the
cervical spine.
Now, normally, if the
patient is experiencing
symptoms of cervical
impingement,
which could be pain
at the neck, shooting
pain down the arms
or the shoulders,
oftentimes a positive
test here is a
reduction of pain due
to the traction force.
It would actually
make the patient feel
better. So once again,
the test is positive.
The pain or
neurologic symptoms of
the cervical spine
and or upper extremity
are reduced with the
traction force. In
other words, it's
almost like a treatment
technique that we
help to relieve the
pressure on the spine,
and a positive test
would actually be a
reduction in pain.
Squirling test, something
also very commonly
done. It's been
around for years, all
right, but it's an
important test to recognize.
This is a test for
cervical nerve root
compression. It's
simple. It's similar to
the axial pyramidal
compression test with a
slight rotatory component.
So as you can see
with the physician
standing behind the
patient, having the
patient look over their
shoulder and then up at
the ceiling. So you're
applying sort of
like an extension and
a rotation, rotatory
force. That's when the
downward compression
as seen by the red
arrow pointing down is
applied to the patient's
head. Okay. Very,
very important. And we
were going to review
this in lab, and the
scholars are going to
be reviewing this as
well. The maneuver
reproduces the neck pain
with radiation to the
arm on the same side
that the head is
turned to. If there is
pain simply with the
positioning in the head
or just moving it into
rotation or extension,
it is not necessary
to apply downward
pressure. It's considered
a positive test.
Ultimately, we're
trying to protect the
sanctity and well-being
of the patient. And a
positive test, just by
putting it in a position,
it's not going to
create any less pain.
It's going to create
more discomfort. So we
would consider that
a positive test. So
slightly different than
the axial pyramidal
compression is the
Spurling with the extension
and rotatory component,
which really isolates
the side of the nerve
root compression.
Next, we have the
straight leg raise with
Braggart's test. This
is a test for radicular
sciatic nerve pain.
As you can see, the
patient is lying
supine with their legs
straight and extended.
What we do here is we
test the unaffected
side first. So the
first thing you do is
always ask the patient,
do you have any pain?
If they say they
have back pain, let's
say on the right leg,
let's say in this
case for the left leg,
we're going to examine
the right side first.
Always examine the
unaffected side first.
Then we raise the
patient's relaxed leg.
We raise the patient's
leg in a relaxed
manner and straighten
by the angle.
Then we place
some panellinia
prevented from bending.
We want literally
a straight
extension component
as we flex the
whole leg upward.
We stop when the patient
feels pain or the
maximal flexion's
been achieved, usually
around 60 to 120 degrees,
sometimes a little
less due to poor
flexibility of some people.
And we repeat that
on the affected side.
The Braggart test
component is where we
lower the leg to a
point just below the
level of the pain. So
the patient reports
pain, let's say, at
60 degrees out. Then
we go another 20 to
30 degrees less, so
we move it down, and
then once we lower
the leg to the point
just below to the
level of pain, we
add a dorsiflexion
component to the foot
on the affected side.
This will undoubtedly
cause an L5
portion of the
sciatic nerve will be
stretched and cause
pain that radiates
below the knee. So
it's an important
thing to add because
it isolates the
specific sciatic
component on that side.
So we know if the pain
is coming from the
leg or from the back
or where it's coming
from location-wise. So
remember to do these
two tests on a practical
assessment. You
will be likely to, if
you're asked to do a
straight leg raise, it
will be likely to be
done with the Braggart's
component as well.
Next, we have the
well-opposite straight
leg raise, or
cross-straight leg
raise, as it's
called. And this test
helps to differentiate
between the sciatic
nerve irritation
and a possible
herniated discus-based
occupying lesion.
This is where
the patient, as
you can see,
is lying supine
with the legs
extended outward.
Then the examiner
has the patient
raise their fully
extended leg on the
uninvolved side.
So in this case,
the patient's likely
has, let's say,
right-sided back
pain or leg pain, and
then we have them
raise the unaffected
side. So in this
case, as he raises the
leg, the test will
indicate a possible
space-occupying lesion
if the pain occurs
on the opposite
side of the leg that
was raised, which,
as we said before,
since we're raised
in the unaffected
side, it goes
intuitively to say that
the pain will be on
the affected side.
So, again, an important
test where we're
looking for some
sort of space or fine
lesion or possible
sciatic nerve irritation,
and this helps
differentiate the two.
Next, we have the
Hoover test. I love
this test. I think
it's an important test.
It's a test that
helps determine
whether a patient's
malignant or end up.
You know, a lot of
patients, for many
reasons, they might want
to get off work. They
might be drug-seeking
medications. So
it's important sometimes
to identify whether
or not the patient's
be lingering if
your suspicions are,
you know, valid. So one
of the tests is the
Hoover test. So with
the patient laying
supine and you standing
at the feet, it's
a unilateral exam.
So the examiner paces
their hand under the
patient's calcaneus,
under their heel,
under their heels
bilaterally, okay, under
the heel, as you can
see in this picture.
What you do is you
instruct the patient
to raise the leg of
the involved side
without bending their
knee. So they're
literally doing a
straight upward leg raise.
So in this case,
let's say the patient
is experiencing a
left-sided back pain.
In this case, you're
going to ask the patient
to raise their left
leg above your hand,
that you're cupping
the hand on the left
leg. So as you're
monitoring that, the
examiner is monitoring
for downward pressure
of the heel on the
side not being tested.
Okay, normally, in
every normal patient,
you can try this at
home, we're going
to practice this in
the lab. When you
naturally lift, you
have a patient lift the
affected side on the
left here, there's
going to be a natural
downward pressure
against the left hand
on the right leg.
Okay, so that's
natural. The test is
positive if there's
an absence of downward
pressure of the
uninvolved foot when the
patient's raising the
involved leg, okay?
I'll repeat that one
more time. The test is
positive if there is an
absence of a downward
pressure of the
uninvolved foot when the
patient is raising
the involved leg. So
hopefully this gives
you better insight as to
understand why this
works. Naturally, we would
be lowering the leg
with the right leg
when the left leg is
raised. But if they're
malingering, this likely
wouldn't happen. Of
course, you want to
combine it with all your
other suspicions and
findings on the test.
But this is a
really good example
of how to help
determine whether or
not a patient
could be malignant.
Again, here's
finally, let's
go over the
neurologic exam.
Again, we start
with the patient
history. This is
more of a recap.
Why do we go to the
neurologic exam? When
do we incorporate the
neurologic exam? If
any or all these
symptoms are presented,
patient reports
coming to you with any
of the following
symptoms, again,
not an exhaustive
list, but really common
things that people
come to their
primary care doctors
or neurologists.
Headache,
dizziness, weakness,
numbness or
abnormal sensation,
syncope or near syncope,
a history of
recent seizure, or
possible tremor
or involuntary
movements. Again,
there are other things
that can be
available, possible,
bowel, bladder,
incontinence,
things like that.
But bottom line
is we want to give
you a general idea
as to when you kind
of combine these
components and when
you do a detailed
neurologic exam.
Common neurologic
complaints. So here's
an example of common
neurologic complaints
such as a headache.
So we broke it down
for you. Patient
reports of a headache.
How do you proceed?
So again, OPQRST,
onset, remember there's
three P's, provocative,
palliative,
progressive. There's two
Q's, quality of life
and quality of the pain,
radiation,
severity, timing,
and associated symptoms.
So you go through
your normal OPQRSTA,
location, duration,
and then other commonly
associated symptoms
that are associated
with headaches. And
go through some of
these. Associated
symptoms are things
that are directly
correlated that we'd be
concerned with if
the patient presented
with the headache,
such as visual changes
of double vision,
sensitivity to light
or sound, weakness,
loss of sensation.
Maybe they have
something like what
we call amorosis
fugax, which is where
a shade's being
pulled over one eye.
Anything like that
that you'd want
to ask about
regarding neurological
complaints associated
with a headache
that would be
concerning that
would require a more
intense workout.
Okay. Take a thorough
past history,
including, of
course, medications,
including what they
take for headaches,
lifestyle changes. Are
they high on coffee,
nicotine, alcohol,
and stress, which can
also increase headaches?
Do they have a
history of migraines?
A lot of times young
men or women have
history of migraines as
a child, and that's
something you definitely
want to document
and keep in mind as
you do your physical
exam and your history.
Here's the common
neurological
complaints for
dizziness and vertigo.
Again, OPQRSTA,
as we said,
knowing the age and
onset and duration.
Again, associated
symptoms. What are
some associated
symptoms that currently
occur with dizziness
and vertigo?
Sensation that the
room is spinning.
Do they feel
it when they go
from sit to stand
or transfer?
Is it associated
with nausea,
vomiting, or even fever?
Do they have a
ringing in the
ear? Do they have
a recent fever?
Any double vision
or problems with
balance or gait?
Have they fallen?
It's really important
to help determine a
history of falls because
then it gets into
more concerning issues
such as based on the
age of the patient,
potential risk factors at
home, history of
falls can lead to hip
fractures and so on and
so forth. So it's really
important to get a
detailed, thorough
history, of course,
including medications,
because a lot of
medications as well as cross
medications can lead
to side effects such as
dizziness and vertigo.
So getting a detailed
medication history
is just as important.
Next, we have
common neurologic
complaints,
including weakness.
Again, this can be
muscle weakness, which
is very common, especially
if it's associated
with a TIA, a trans
-esteem sickness attack,
or a ******, a
cerebrovascular accident.
Knowing where the
weakness is, is
it unilateral or
bilateral? Is it
localized to the
upper or lower
legs? Is it localized
to the face?
Is there a drooliness
of their mouth or a
weakness in their eyes
or facial muscles?
Is it unilateral
or bilateral?
Look for patterns
of weakness.
Notice where
the patient says
they feel weak
and then places
they may not
have realized,
right? Proximal versus
distal muscles are
huge. Why is this
important? Because if
there's a history
of potential ******,
localizing where
the weakness occurs,
whether it be face,
proximal, distal
muscles, will help us
determine the actual
location within the
circle of Willis or
somewhere in the
brain where the ******
occurs. So we'll know
where to look for
the MRI, or CAT scan
for that matter.
Associated symptoms
with weakness
can include
fatigue, apathy,
drowsiness, loss
of strength, mental
status changes,
slurred speech, as well
as aphasia. So taking
a thorough history
as well as a social
history, such as
diet and exercise and
history of smoking,
which all have
significant risk factors
associated with
weakness relating to
TIAs, CVAs, and
heart issues as well.
Next, we have common
neurological complaints
with numbness,
abnormal, or absence of
sensation. So here we
want to ask not just the
OBQRST, but what's
the quality of the
numbness? Is it tingling
like pins and needles?
Are there times when
you don't feel it
at all? Is it worse
when you lean on a
particular arm? Is
there reduced or
completely absence
sensation or anesthesia.
A lot of times, a
common thing that a lot
of people experience,
and I'm sure many of
you have, is an ulnar
neuropathy at the
elbow. A lot of times,
people, the way they
sleep, they sometimes
wake up in the middle
of the night with an
absence of sensation
to the one and a
half digits of the
pinky and the ring
finger. So a lot of times,
you can feel that.
And oftentimes, that's
just due to an ulnar
entrapment neuropathy
that occurs overnight.
Once you reposition
yourself, it goes
away. But it's a
simple example of
something that a lot of
people tend to feel.
Is it associated with
burning or irritating
sensations? What's the
pattern of the
paresthesias? Is it a
stocking glove distribution,
which is common
with peripheral
neuropathy as a diabetics?
Germatomal distribution,
which can be
associated with
potentially cervical or
lumbar irritated
nerve root or patchy
areas of sensory loss.
So really taking a
thorough history and
breaking down the
components as to
exactly where the
abnormal sensation
is occurring. And of
course, you'll determine
in your physical
exam, but getting a
really good picture
is an idea to get to
the right diagnosis.
Next, we have syncope
or neurosyncope.
All right, the sense
of feeling that you're
going to pass out or
actually passing out.
Always ask the
patient, was
there a loss of
consciousness?
Did anything happen
just priorly? What was
the prodromal phase
like? What happened right
before? Did you
experience any pain? Any
loss of vision? Any
weird sounds or external
noises? Were you
lightheaded or dizzy? Did
you have any chest pain?
Did you have fever?
You know,
any kind of any taking
a detailed history
of present illness
or HPI here is
vital to understanding
the possible causes
of why they passed
out or why they
feel alone, why they
lost consciousness.
again how long did
they lose consciousness
for was there a
complete loss what were
you doing at the time
of onset one of my
favorite questions to
ask standing were you
standing sitting or
lying down why is that
important well it's
important because if
they were standing
and they fell there
could be other subsequent
sequelae such as
you know possible
fractures bruise bones
muscles strains things
like that and also
it puts them at risk
especially for further
episodes of syncope
if they're not safe.
Are there any other
triggers or warning
symptoms? How
long did it last?
And how quickly did
the onset occur?
Was there anyone
at home or
where, if it was at work,
would anyone else
witness it? And any other
associated symptoms,
as I said before?
Any of these things,
a detailed HPI
will always give
you an extremely
good insight as to
what the cause of
the signal episode
may or may not be.
Next, we have common
neurological complaints
of seizures. If a
patient presents with
a recent history of
seizure, how do we
present? How did it
onset? Was it once or
multiple times? Many
times I've had patients
come in, they usually
had a history of
seizures. It might've
been months or years
before the last one,
but it's important to
identify if they have
a history of them.
Did they lose
consciousness?
Was it one-sided
or bilateral?
What parts of the
body were affected?
How old was the
patient? Very important.
Ask them about history
of head trauma.
Were they in a motor
vehicle accident
recently or years ago?
Did they ever fall
on their head? Any
of these things can
really lead to an
important understanding
as to whether or
not this could be
something that's due
to a traumatic episode
or something even
more important, a
pathological issue going
on within the brain
itself, such as tumors
or something along
those lines of mass
undefined nature.
Associated symptoms,
always, always, always
ask about the bladder,
bowel, incontinence,
drowsiness or impaired
memory after the
event, which is
common, and tongue
biting. We need to always
protect the airway,
make sure that they're
safe and they're
able, that they
didn't have an episode
of vomiting. Did
they eat recently?
You've got to be worried
about aspiration,
right? And then we
asked about fevers
as well, as well as
the rest of their
medical history. Any
history, as I said, head
trauma, ******,
diabetes, meningitis,
and so on and so
forth. And the medical
history, social history
about drug and alcohol
use is important
too. So some or all
these can also cause
episodes of seizure.
******* overdose,
as well as benzo
withdrawals, can
actually lead to induced
seizures. So keep
those things in mind.
And that's why the
social history is
so vital in these
cases that present.
Next, we have common
neurological complaints
of tremors and
involuntary movements.
So once we complete
our OPQRST,
some of the things
we ask about, right?
Facial dyskinesias
or tics.
Do the patient
have any history
of any snake-like
movement in their
arms or abnormal
kind of wavy
-like motions of
their arms or legs?
Where do they
occur if they
do? What area
of the body?
Is it arms,
legs, or in the
face? Is there
a facial tape?
Does it occur at
rest? Does it occur
at certain times
of the day? Does
it occur with
increased stress?
Asking them all
these questions.
Is it repetitive
and coordinated?
Does it increase or
decrease in voluntary
movement? Okay. What
type of movement
triggers the involuntary
movements? All
right. So getting a
detailed medical social
history, especially
neurologic exam,
things like
Huntington's, Parkinson's
disease, and other sort
of neurologic pathologies
need to be asked
about. And medications,
of course, because
medications can
actually cause some
or all these symptoms.
And asking about
family members to
a detailed family
history is really
vital in these
cases, especially
if they're
presenting with this.
here's some examples
of tic and involuntary
movements the one on
the left here shows an
oral facial dyskinesias
um with the tongue
movements um on the
right side we see tics
where there's a kind
of like a stereotype
coordinated movement
involving at irregular
intervals including
repetitive winking or
grimacing or shoulder
shrugging that can occur
And then dystonias
we see here
cause irregular movements
resembling apoptosis
or a tremor.
And then down below
here, we have examples
of an apoptoid movement
with the hands,
which are more
twisting and writhing,
like a chorea form
movement that's
associated with Huntington's.
And then finally,
a chorea movement
on the bottom right
here. These are what
we call brief, rapid,
jerky, irregular,
and unpredictable.
They can occur at
rest or interrupt
normal four
-day movements,
and they occur
out of the blue.
Patients have no
control over them,
but they can be very
unsightly and very
uncomfortable and
really affect the
patient's ability
to live a regular
life that they need
to be looked into.
Finally, let's look at
some preventable numbers.
****** is an important
diagnosis. It's
something you
don't want to miss.
patients who present
with weakness,
aphasias, or an episode
of what's possibly
a CVA or cerebrovascular
accident,
any risk factors for
strokes can always
be broken up into, and
this goes with heart
disease as well, as
modifiable versus
non-modifiable risk
factors. There's a lot
of things patients
can do, or things that
they do do, I should
say, that increase
their risk for ******.
And those things
that are modifiable
are things that we can
change and have a
positive effect on.
High blood pressure
for one, hypertension,
taking medications
and living a
healthy lifestyle
can lower that.
Diabetes is also
a risk factor. So
managing, controlling
blood sugars,
monitoring A1Cs are
important as well.
History of smoking.
Smoking is directly
and inherently correlated
to an increased
risk for ******. So
we really want to get
an insight as to the
patient's history
or smoking history,
and then make a
determination and how
we want to best proceed.
Dyslipidemia or high
lipids and cholesterol
are always shown
to improve or can
definitely increase
the risk for ischemic
strokes, so that's
something we need to do
when we get to evaluate
the blood panel.
And sedentary
lifestyle. Sedentary
lifestyle leads to
many or all the things
just listed above
it. It certainly
doesn't help.
Maintaining an active
life is maintaining
a healthy life.
Next, we have a
screening for diabetic
peripheral neuropathy.
I think it's
important to kind of
just give an overview.
Again, this is one
of the more common
presenting complaints to
a clinic, maybe family
medicine, certainly
in a neurology clinic.
Especially early on,
diabetic patients
are very unaware of
their neuropathy. They
may not even realize
they have it because
there's a lost sensation,
often distally,
where they don't
feel what's going on.
And they're
also unaware of
their sensory
loss as well.
And as it says here,
distal symmetric
polyneuropathy is the
most common neuropathy for
these patients. It
happens both sides,
like I said before,
in a stocking blood
distribution, the sensory
loss. But the problem
really lies with loss
of sensation, let's
say, in the feet.
They can step on a
thumbtack or a nail or a
splinter. And if they're
not examining their
feet regularly, that
can lead to significant
infection, possible
vascular damage, and
even loss of limb.
And it can happen
fairly quickly, within
less than a year. So
it's really important
to really educate
these patients on
understanding how they
can combat any NPV and
practice preventative
medicine and helping
to maintain a healthy
life as possible.
They're a risk factor
for ulceration,
arthropathy,
and amputations.
Prevalence can be
20% long-term type 1
diabetics and 50% in
type 2, probably more
because there's many
more type 2s than type
1s. But important to
maintain tight glycemic
control, routine
foot exams, assessing
for neuropathies, as
stated here, plantar,
light touch sensation,
skin breakdown.
And it doesn't say it
here, but make sure
you always get at
least once a year an
ophthalmologic exam. Go
visit the ophthalmologist
because there's a lot
of diseases that can
also affect possible
diabetes and lead to
blindness, especially
sore control buildup
in the thomac arteries.
But it really is
important because
diabetes can be associated
with significant ocular
pathologies as well.
Finally, here
is an example,
as I've shown
you in the past,
of a normal
neurologic exam.
I won't go through
the whole thing,
but this is more
for your references.
You can see here
everything is listed
as it was in the
previous slides, in
the previous two
lectures, all the
way down to deep
tendon reflexes here.
Moving on to the
next slide, we have
documentation of normal
cranial nerve exam.
Again, just to reiterate,
if the higher exam
is normal, you won't
have to write this
all out every time.
Obviously, if you're doing
a detailed or a logical
exam for one of the
presenting complaints
that I mentioned
earlier, you certainly
want to do it. But
essentially what you're
doing here and on the
next slide, cranial
nerves 2 through 12
can be done. The exam
can be done in just
two to three minutes.
And then if everything's
normal or checks
out, you can simply
write cranial nerves
2 through 12 grossly
intact bilaterally,
except for cranial
nerve 5 on the left,
cranial nerve 7 on the
left, something like
that. You can really
simplify your writing.
Summary. It's
important to take
a good history
when evaluating
anyone with a
neurologic problem.
Neurologic diagnosis
can be obtained
through performing
a thorough exam that
includes testing of
the motor and sensory
systems, coordination,
gait, and reflexes,
in addition to the
cranial nerves.
It's important to know
how to document these.
And again, there
were examples of
documentation, not only
in this particular slide,
but it'll be on your
skill sheets as well.
So when you're
reviewing everything for
the labs upcoming,
please make sure you
review those skill
sheets. There's examples
of proper documentation
of each system on
the particular skill
sheets you're reading.
There's a list of your
references or
your records.
So you have that
as well, as well
as this, dates,
and textbook.
Again, preparation
for this final neuro
lab. As always, be
dressed in DPR attire and
bring your
ophthalmoscope. If we have
time, we will try to
get through and practice
more of the total
neuro exam if we have
time towards the end.
And of course, please,
please, please review
those neurologic
DPR skill sheets prior
to coming to lab.
Sometimes the labs are
dense, as I've said
before, and it can be
very, very difficult
with everything we
need to do and get
through to get through
every single skill.
But we will definitely
cover as many as
possible. But your
ability to review these
skills prior to
lab is vital to
understanding and also
won't take unnecessary
time away from your
practice time as well.
And that's it. I thank
you for your time.
I hope you have a
great rest of your day.
As always, you may
ask me any questions
regarding this in lab
down the line. The first
slide has my email.
It's been a pleasure
lecturing all of you
and I look forward to
seeing you all in lab.
So thank you very much.
Thank you.